Pamela Diaz says her 12 year old
grandson feels guilty he wasn't able to
save his mother AJ Owens how do you
explain this loss you can't because I
still can't believe that this happened
when
does a person get shot
for knocking on a door last Friday
owens's children were playing in a field
near Susan lorenz's Ocala Florida home
police say Lorenz became angry she
yelled and threw a roller skate at them
when Owens knocked on Lawrence's door
looking for answers Lorenz fired a
gunshot through the door hitting Owens
in the chest
community and family members are Furious
Lorenz wasn't arrested right away Lorenz
claims self-defense and police say the
four-day delay in her arrest was because
of Florida's stand your ground law it
allows deadly force if someone believes
they're in imminent danger